What if I told you that one of the
world's most famous liberation movements
was secretly controlled by Russian spies?
That major terrorist attacks were
actually KGB operations
disguised as Palestinian resistance.
Welcome to my channel. I'm here because I
believe we deserve better than propaganda
disguised as history.
disguised as history. Today
Today we're using declassified documents
to separate fact from fiction.
I'm exposing one of the Cold War's most
successful deception campaigns
using files that intelligence agencies
try to keep secret for
decades. Picture this, it's 1967.
1967 Israel just crushed its
Israel just crushed its
neighbors in the Six-Day War.
neighbors in the Six-Day War
Soviet allies are humiliated
Soviet allies are humiliated.
KGB chairman Yuri
KGB Chairman Yuri
Andropov is facing a crisis.
Andropov is facing a crisis
Soviet prestige
shattered.
shattered Middle East
Middle East diplomacy
dominated by America.
Moscow desperately needs a new strategy
Moscow desperately needs a new strategy.
The solution comes from a
KGB manual. If you are good at
KGB manual if you are good at
Disinformation you can get away with
disinformation, you can get away with
anything. But here's what
makes this story complicated.
makes this story complicated
Palestinian resistance existed long
before the Soviets
showed up. Back in 1936,
1936 the Arab revolt
the Arab revolt forced Britain
to deploy over 20,000 troops.
120,000 troops over
Over 20,000 Arab Palestinians were
killed, wounded or imprisoned.
This was 30 years before
major Soviet involvement.
So let me be crystal clear the KGB didn't
So let me be crystal clear, the KGB
didn't create Palestinian nationalism.
create Palestinian nationalism
They weaponized it now. Let's talk about
They weaponized it. Now,
let's talk about the smoking gun.
the smoking gun. It's
It's called the Mitrokhin archive, one of
the most comprehensive
intelligence leaks in history.
intelligence leaks in history
These aren't rumors. These aren't
conspiracy theories.
aren't conspiracy theories
These are the KGB's own secret files now
These are the KGB's own secret files, now
sitting at Cambridge University, right
next to Winston Churchill's papers.
Churchill's papers and
And what do these documents tell us?
What do these documents tell us?
That the popular front for the liberation
of Palestine was, and I quote,
of Palestine was and I quote
created and financed by the KGB
"created and financed by the KGB".
But that's just the beginning the
But that's just the beginning. The
penetration went much, much deeper.
deeper meet what the hadad
Meet Wadi Haddad. He was
the PFLP's top operative.
He was the PFL peace top operative in
In 1970, the KGB recruited
him as agent nationalist.
internal reports show chairman Andropov
Internal reports show Chairman Andropov
bragging to Soviet leader Brezhnev
bragging to Soviet leader Brezhnev that
that this relationship let them control
the external operations of
the PFLP to a certain degree.
But Moscow's real prize was Agent GIDAR,
recruited in Moscow in 1968
recruited in Moscow in 1968,
placed directly inside Arafat's inner
circle as his most
trusted intelligence advisor.
trusted intelligence advisor
Think about that the Russians literally
Think about that. The Russians literally
had a spy feeding them everything from
Palestinian leadership meetings.
Palestinian leadership meetings
The logistics were massive. There's this
operation called Vostok.
operation called Vostok a Soviet ship
A Soviet ship sails from Radivostok all
the way to Yemen,
nighttime weapons transfers
nighttime weapons transfers.
We're talking advanced
radio-controlled mines,
radio controlled mines
silenced weapons and foreign-made RMS
silenced weapons and foreign-made arms
specifically chosen to
height our Soviet origin.
height our Soviet origin
These weren't your typical leftover
These weren't your
typical leftover Kalashnikovs.
Ion Pacepa, the highest-ranking Soviet
intelligence officer to ever defect,
intelligence officer to ever defect
Tells us the KGB trained over 100
tells us the KGB trained over 100
operatives every year.
operatives every year
people from the Middle East
People from the Middle East, Africa,
Africa Europe all at their secret
Europe, all at their
secret facility near Moscow.
facility in near Moscow the curriculum
The curriculum, intelligence work,
intelligence work
surveillance, advanced sabotage...
Surveillance advanced sabotage the
The results were devastating.
results were devastating
KGB files showed their Palestinian
KGB files show their Palestinian proxies
pulled off the first simultaneous
aircraft hijacking in 1970.
1970 that's 31 years before 9-11
That's 31 years before 9-11.
plus
Plus bombings across
Europe throughout the decade.
decade, but the most important operation
But the most important operation? You
couldn't see it at all.
you couldn't see it at all
Here's where this gets really sinister.
Here's where this gets really sinister
According to Pacepa's CIA testimony the
According to Pashepa's CIA testimony, the
KGB didn't just hand out weapons.
KGB didn't just hand out weapons. They
They systematically rewrote Palestinian
history, starting with
their leader's identity.
Starting with their leaders identity the
The KGB destroyed Yasser
Arafat's real Cairo bird records.
Then they created
fake Jerusalem documents.
fake Jerusalem documents
They manufactured his entire origin story
to make him more sympathetic to
international audiences.
international audiences
This wasn't just recruitment. This was
identity engineering.
identity engineering, but
But the messaging
transformation? That was revolutionary.
That was revolutionary
North Vietnamese General Giap gave
North Vietnamese general Jap gave
Palestinian leaders some advice.
He told them to stop talking about
annihilating Israel and instead turn your
terror war into a
struggle for human rights.
Brilliant, right?
The Mitrokhin archive shows how the KGB
took Arafat's simple four-page pamphlet
and turned it into a
48-page monthly magazine,
distributed around the entire Arab world.
They weren't just manufacturing weapons
They weren't just manufacturing weapons.
They were manufacturing narratives
They were manufacturing narratives.
Narratives that are
still being used today.
Every Soviet disinformation operation
followed something called the
"Kernel of Truth Principle".
the kernel of truth principle
Start with something
real, something verifiable.
real something verifiable
Then build layers of
Then build layers of deception around it.
deception around it the goal
The goal? Making sure that, in their
words, the slander
would never be put to rest.
put to rest and it worked
And it worked devastatingly well.
Devastatingly well what started as an
What started as an ethnic conflict got
repackaged as a
universal human rights struggle.
You can see the exact same messaging
techniques in campus movements today,
Decades after the Soviet Union collapsed
decades after the Soviet Union collapsed.
now, here's where history gets
Now, here's where history gets
complicated and we need to
be honest about the evidence.
be honest about the evidence
Despite all this operational penetration
Despite all this operational penetration,
Leading scholars like Oxford's Yazid
leading scholars like
Oxford's Yezid Sayigh
Zayik showed the KGB never
show the KGB never
achieved complete control.
Zayik's research is based on PLO archives
"Sayigh's research is based on PLO
archives and over 400 interviews.
interviews. What does it reveal?
What does it reveal? Consistent
Palestinian defiance of Soviet pressure.
defiance of Soviet pressure
They refused to recognize Israel. They
kept their maximalist goals.
kept their maximalist goals
They chose military solutions even when
Moscow wanted diplomacy.
Palestinians also
diversified their support.
support money from Arab oil
Money from Arab oil
states, from China, from others.
states from China from others
political scientists note
Political scientists note this allowed
small powers to resist
attempts by great power allies
Resist attempts by great power allies to
to curtail their freedom of action.
We also need to acknowledge something
We also need to acknowledge
something about our sources.
about our sources the British Parliament
The British Parliament called the
Mitrokhin archive tremendously valuable.
tremendously valuable but
But historians remind us that when
governments run disinformation campaigns,
written evidence may be very misleading
written evidence may be very misleading.
This doesn't make the documented KGB
operations less significant.
significant. It adds crucial context
It adds crucial context.
The Soviets weaponized existing
Palestinian nationalism.
Palestinian nationalism
They didn't create it from nothing. They
They didn't create it from nothing.
They exploited genuine grievances while
pursuing their own strategic goals.
So why does this 50 year old story matter
So why does this
50-year-old story matter today?
today because the
Because the connections
are direct and ongoing.
connections are direct and ongoing
current Palestinian Authority president
Current Palestinian
Authority President Mahmoud Abbas
Mahmoud Abbas was educated
was educated at
Moscow's Lumumba University.
That's where the KGB recruited students
That's where the KGB recruited students.
his advisor was Vladimir Kisolev who
His advisor was Vladimir Kisolev, who
worked for future Russian Prime Minister
worked for future Russian prime minister
Yevgeny Primakov Putin's Middle East
Yevgeny Primakov.
Putin's Middle East strategy directly
continues these Cold War relationships.
Russian weapons found in
recent Hezbollah operations,
They include systems produced as recently
they include systems
produced as recently as 2020.
as 2020 these aren't coincidences
These aren't coincidences.
They're the evolution of networks
established during the Soviet era.
established during the Soviet era most
Most importantly, the narrative
techniques pioneered by the KGB,
pioneered by the KGB
they're still influencing how we discuss
Middle Eastern politics.
Middle Eastern politics the
The transformation from ethnic conflict
to human rights struggle remains
Struggle remains the dominant framework
the dominant framework in universities,
in universities media and
media and international institutions.
This is exactly why I made this channel
This is exactly why I made this channel.
complex historical realities
Complex historical realities resist
simple explanations.
The documented evidence shows the KGB
achieved extraordinary operational reach
Operational reach while never gaining
while never gaining
complete political control.
complete political control their most
Their most lasting victory
wasn't on any battlefield.
It was in the realm of ideas. I'm not
It was in the realm of ideas.
I'm not here to tell you what to think
about current events.
I'm here to show you what the declassified
I'm here to show you what declassified
documents reveal about how we got here.
documents reveal about how we got here
Understanding the difference between
authentic grievances and
manufactured narratives,
that's crucial for
making sense of today's world.
making sense of today's world
If you believe that history deserves
better than propaganda,
better than propaganda whether it comes
whether it comes from Moscow,
from Moscow Washington or anywhere else
Washington or anywhere else,
Then please subscribe because in a world
then please subscribe, because in a world
of competing narratives,
of competing narratives
The most powerful weapon is simply
the most powerful weapon is simply
showing people the documents.
showing people the documents
Please let me know what other accepted
historical narratives
historical narratives. Do you think need?
do you think need
re-examination using evidence.
Reexamination using evidence
Remember, when someone
controls the narrative,
narrative that's exactly when it's good
that's exactly when it's
good to start asking questions.
to start asking questions